all right well i think we are back and
so we had a little bit of technical
difficulties as sometimes might happen
in the internet uh uh but ernest you
were going through your explanation and
uh you're talking about uh kind of how
at moorhouse you were able to work with
these tech companies and you were able
to
you know you discovered the magic of
software engineering which i experienced
something very similar when i first
learned that you could code and make
almost anything in the world i have one
question similar to uh where delecia's
narrative went which was
when you applied to morehouse how much
were finance is an issue what did
financial aid look like um or or
or you know what did the debt situation
look like and what what made you
confident that it was it was worth the
investment
we might have lost earnest
so let me let me
let me move to madison madison i'll ask
you the same question asked alicia and
ernest which is
how did you think about it when you were
leaving high school college right for
you if so what college what major
how did money factor into it
yeah so um i'll give you a little bit of
personal information about myself i'm
actually a first generation american um
so my parents were adamant about me kind
of fulfilling that dream for them going
to college and i knew that was
definitely
the only choice i had but
um i can tell you
i guess thinking about my 16 year old
self it was terrifying to
essentially perceive the job market as
something i'm doing for the rest of my
life you know of course that that myth
was dispelled during my college years
you know it's not necessarily one thing
i have to do for the rest of my life but
being 16 that's what i thought of it
about i'm like wow i really have to pick
something and i have to just stick with
it for the rest my life and that that
thought haunted me for a while um so uh
before high school my parents certainly
wanted me to be a doctor 100 like they
were convinced i was going to be a
doctor they're like yep you're going to
work at the same hospital your father
does and you're gonna do this and i'm
like okay you know your parents you kind
of just go with it but
as i progressed even in middle school i
just knew i loved art
and as much as you know house and a
bunch of other doctor shows interest me
and i i loved working with you know
people i liked art more and that was
something that
i needed to realize in high school and
i'm just like okay like
you know 16 year old me logic was if i
was going to do something for the rest
of my life i need to like it
so i started researching what i can do
in art and i think that just opened up
my mind to the possibilities of where i
can go and what i can do and you know
design being such a broad subject and a
broad major i can go into several
different things which you know i'll
definitely go into being like more
multifaceted a little bit later but
um in terms of you know picking college
i was looking around and there were some
local ones i'm originally from new
jersey so i was looking at rutgers
montclair seton hall all these state
schools
didn't like ernest didn't really know
about much about hbcus at all but i had
a friend whose older brother did go to
attend howard and he just came back and
there was something just different about
him i don't know what it was i just i'm
like oh he seems like more confident he
seems
you know
i don't know it was it's like a aura
almost and i was like hey let me just
ask and i think asking those questions
and seeking that guidance and help from
him really helped me
in order to make my college decision and
i was fortunate enough to you know take
a weekend trip down to dc and just step
on campus and really
feel the environment and i do suggest
for you know my students out there try
to if you can if you have the means to
and the ability to
go to the universities that you are
interested in and feel you know ask
questions stop the student you know
students like to talk
ask them hey what do you like about your
university what would you like to see
improved what's your favorite part
um
and on howard's campus i was able to
just talk to so many people and i'm like
wow these people are so cool and
you know
i wish there was more technicality and
rhyme and reason to my story but it was
really just because i love that campus
uh that art department was great um a
lot of people on that campus had the
same interests as me um
and yeah that's pretty much my
my story on how i got here
yeah there's there's two at least at
least two big takeaways i took from
yours is it is true oftentimes you're 16
or 17 years old and you think
what major you choose or where you go to
college is going to you know the die is
cast for the rest of your life but i
think one of the narratives and we heard
it with delisha's is that she thought
she was going to do one thing she did
another thing and now she's ended up in
a completely different thing that as
long as you're doing things that are
helping you grow your general skills and
your thinking you might have a lot of
options available another thing that you
talked about which is you you asked a
lot of questions you have that
that family friend who went to howard
you asked them a lot of questions you
went to the campus you asked a lot of
questions so what i'm hearing is just
the power
of asking
a lot of people
a lot of questions
um you know going into it i have a ton
of questions this is unusual how many
questions we're getting off of social
media so you all are very popular more
popular than i tend to be when i'm just
doing this
by myself but let me jump into some of
them so i have this question for ernest
greatest american daniel asks
interesting username what is it like
being a software engineer what do you do
daily what's your day-to-day like ernest
can you hear me now are we good yes yes
we can
great great great great oh love to
answer that question being a software
engineer in the tech industry period but
especially at google is one of the best
jobs i think you can do in the world
there's no other company that you can
come to
uh get to work whenever you want i would
say that um
you know be surrounded by volleyball
courts basketball courts swimming pools
video games on every corner gourmet food
in every cafe and the best part about
the food is it's all free like google it
has a theory that like if they give
their employees
every benefit possible and make sure
that the their employees are the most
relaxed and comfortable in the workplace
then productivity will go up and i guess
it's been working because google has
been making millions and not billions
and
of impact and dollars
a different engineer truly looks as um
you come to the office when you need
when you're ready to um
you have me personally i'll go get some
breakfast some nice bacon egg and cheese
sandwich maybe depending on how i feel
uh check my email
make sure i'm caught up with everything
with my manager and then i'm probably
working on one of
maybe three or four projects so i start
hacking away at some of them so i write
some code by that time after like 30
minutes an hour it's already lunch time
so i'll go get some lunch and lunch is
amazing and google has food for every
different background we could think of
food from all parts of the world so if
you want sushi one day you can get sushi
to fried chicken to a burger to a
burrito um
and then in the afternoon this is
normally where you have a lot of
meetings you're meeting with your team
working make sure everyone is getting
their code done that it needs to be done
and honestly my day probably i probably
get in office at like 10 and then i'll
leave around four
as long as i'm getting all my work done
it doesn't really matter what times of
the day you're working it's more if
you're you're getting your project done
when you said you're going to get it
done bottom line is
best job in the world i personally think
well i i think you're you're doing a
great job recruiting for for google i'm
sure i'm sure
and i look i think by any objective
measure google is a very solid uh
employer employer to work for you know
just i'll that question about the day to
day i think that is intriguing for all
of y'all and i'll add there's another
question from youtube jay mccall how did
you guys know these were the jobs you
wanted and love doing maybe i'll go to
you first alicia on this one one if you
want to say anything about your day to
day that's always interesting uh what
you're doing on a day-to-day basis but
also
how did you zero in on this one um and
where is it on that spectrum how much
you love it
right i'll just add a little bit about
my day-to-day i will say i'm not at
google but it is great like google
because i also get to choose my own
flexibility and schedule as well
um so that's very awesome um and then
just
as far as sorry what was the other
question it's on my other day-to-day no
and how did you
well one what's your day-to-day which it
sounds like you also get some
flexibility in yours but also
you know how did you gravitate towards
this you alluded to a little bit you're
in psychology you're interested in
psychology which is objectively a very
interesting field as is cyber security
but then
what made you do the leap was there an
opening and and he's like hey that's
kind of cool let me just see what that
is and you're like i kind of enjoyed
this how did you fall into this and
realize you like it
it was actually a byway of non-profit so
for several years i actually served as a
college advisor
with a with an organization not called
college advising corps if you've heard
of it and we've actually worked with
college board before and
i was serving and supporting high school
students like who were like me
first generation
who had never family had never went to
college so i was supporting them with
the whole college process from college
applications to essays to registering
for their s-a-t-a-c-t
giving them scholarship lists making
sure they apply for scholarships
getting ready for graduation if they
weren't ready or did not want to go to
college they're not supporting them
through signing up for the military or
finding other careers and opportunities
that weren't related to college that
would still provide them with
opportunity to make a change and create
generational wealth for their family
so from there i realized okay i'm on the
beginning side of education where i'm
supporting them and i'm getting them to
the door to graduate from my school and
to get into college and i'm seeing them
walk through in their first year
of college and do all those great things
but now i want to support them beyond
that step how can i get on the other
side which is higher education and
support them through the actual college
journey um so that's when i actually did
some research i started searching i
actually stumbled upon a science
technology institute to be honest with
you i thought i was like does this
really exist this is one of those scam
jobs online because you can never be too
careful
it's kind of ironic that i it's a top
security college so even
then i was a bit skeptical um but i
looked into it do some research and then
i realized that they were part of the
best
cyber security leader in industry um in
the whole country and i said okay i'm
going to give it a chance so although i
didn't have experience in higher
education at that time i had never
worked as a student advisor in a higher
education setting or for a college i
applied anyway i stepped out on faith
out better on myself and i said okay i'm
going to take this step i'm going to bid
on myself and i'm going to apply and
that's just what i did i was afraid i
was scared i was nervous
but i got a call back and several
interviews later i landed the job and
we're knocking on two years in december
and i haven't looked back since and i'm
so thankful for the opportunity and i've
learned so much about cyber security it
is so interesting and i'm just excited
to to teach and
and inspire those out there who are
watching this to want to
defend again like our cyber work because
cyber security is going to be and is a
huge and critical piece
um of our infrastructure in this country
and it's something that we're going to
need more people regardless of what
major or career path you come from
regardless of your background
you don't have to fit a mode there's no
prototype of what you need to look like
or
be or like or do
to join cyber security we want people
from all walls so like whether you're
into art and you're really good at it or
you're really good at software
engineering we need all of you from all
walks of life to come into the world of
cyber security to bring your diverse
perspectives
and to help us save the world
yeah
very few jobs we could incredibly talk
about saving the world and one i i was
very entertained by the notion that you
thought the the the cyber certi security
college might itself be some type of a
fishing attack
you might have uh but but also i think
you know i hear it in your voice the joy
of and this is i think education
generally but being an advisor because
you get a multiplier effect on your job
you're helping other people discover
their journeys and then they will then
help save the planet
hopefully
um madison what what about on your side
and i'll i'll i'll give a slightly
different flavor to the question which
is
it's one thing for you early on to say
hey you know i like art more than i like
health care but there's another thing
where the the education and what you do
in school might be pretty different than
what you end up doing for a job i've
seen people who go to school for one
thing but then when they get the job
they're like oh this is what i have to
do on a day-to-day basis
what was it was was was the transition
from school which it sounded like you
really enjoyed art school or the design
aspects of it to work was it as you were
expecting was it better than expected
was it worse than expected how did you
navigate that
i think this is a a very very personal
question to me um it was nothing like my
undergrad experience i can say
my internship experiences in undergrad
reflect me being interested in so many
different things my freshman year i
stayed as a campus mentor on howard's
campus just giving doors talking to
people answering the same questions that
i asked as a senior um being a freshman
i got some answers so
i was able to relay that my sophomore
year i was a accounting intern at att's
government military headquarters in
virginia which is totally outside of
design and i can you know go on in the
days but
um
my junior i was able to
intern with new york fashion week which
was something i've never done before i
ended up in new york for a weekend
really just running around and
experiencing that
and my senior year is when i actually
landed my dream internship with att in
el segundo california um essentially
working in their entertainment sector
which is right on the merge of their
merger with uh time warner um and it was
the craziest experience
ever
and after college i actually um i
received an offer from atnt but it
wasn't necessarily what i wanted to do
um more on the side of
not in the location where i wanted
texas i didn't really know anyone so i
i made the very unpopular decision of
declining that offer which is
at the time i regretted you know all my
friends were going to these major places
and i was still kind of home so i was
like uh what's going on
that's when i i decided to start small
with aji um building up you know some
clients i had in college as well as some
local businesses and really just honing
in on my craft a bit more while working
kind of a um
there's a term they use in la when
actors are waiting for their big break
but they're kind of just in transit i
had an in-transit job
and didn't really like it but i knew
design was what i wanted to do so i kept
working um i actually ended up interning
last year with a pentagram for those who
are familiar with the design in the
world it's actually the largest
independently designed firm in the world
i worked under eddiopar and michael beru
and
busted my butt for
about a year learning learning more and
growing and understanding and you know
some some nights ernest's gonna test i
stayed up until like two o'clock in the
morning learning things
and trying to get better and
a couple months ago i accepted this job
with cnn which is my dream job so
my path is definitely a winding road and
not a straight path whatsoever so to
answer your question no it was nothing
like
what i expected or what i imagined
you know there's this theme that i'm
getting from all of y'all and this is
true of my journey as well that you know
there's a lot of things that maybe your
college and your major might have helped
you with but at the end of the day a lot
of it is
in each of your journeys you're asking
questions you're constantly learning
doing more and more things there's a
bunch of questions i'm getting around
grades and test scores for example
calvin tran says do grades determine if
you're going to be successful alejandro
garcia can your scores on the s.a.t or
act determine which careers may be good
for you let's see there's another
question
lower i think someone was asking i think
they've been discouraged for going into
certain fields maybe because they don't
feel they have the grades or the test
scores
what advice
do you have for students who are who are
because obviously when you're in high
school and a lot of college your grades
and your test scores seem to matter a
lot
how do you all think about that and what
have you seen in your own lives or
people around you uh maybe i'll randomly
select earnest you you go first
yeah um
i came from a family where education was
the foundation of everything like we
couldn't do
my sister and i did theater growing up
we were in karate we did different
sports we couldn't do extracurriculars
if we
weren't
tight on our grades and our parents
actually praised us all the time and we
got honors role honorable or high honors
and setting that foundation early in our
lives really put us on a great academic
path um all the way up into college
right we're always striving to be in
um
honor
classes ap classes and then college of
honors program and dean's list and all
that so i will always say
it is important to have a strong
educational basis because that actually
helps you also have the right discipline
with everything else that you do in life
just because you're working at a job at
google as a software engineer and you're
not getting a's and b's and c's does not
mean that you're not awesome
you're still going to be graded
on how well you're performing at your
job as well so everything is always
associated with one another that being
said companies like google don't
actually require you to have a certain
gpa to come work or even apply and
actually encourage all students no
matter what gpa they have or what
situation they're they're in to always
apply to all these companies because we
need to
uh always have
people from a bunch of different
backgrounds with a bunch of different um
thought processes right
and
but i still
strongly recommend that you focus in on
your grades get those good grades
because good grades can lead to a lot of
different things sal you're about to
bring up earlier um we're about to talk
a little bit about affording college
college is expensive like we talked
about right but the thing is especially
with great academics and make helps get
you scholarships so you can actually
afford college the other thing
also with tech industry jobs if you guys
don't know i mentioned earlier i
interned at google an internship is when
you actually go
uh leave when you don't leave school but
like during the summer when you're
normally on summer break you're actually
going to work at these different
companies and these internships are
actually paid google's internship alone
on the summer you probably can make
somewhere between 12 to 15 000
that's a lot of money that can you you
can take and put right back into your
education um so
that's why i'm very
big on students making sure that they're
staying strong in their academics um not
so that they can get a 3.5 so they can
get internship at google but so they
have that discipline they have those um
foundations in order to be successful to
be able to get a job or internship at
google so then you can then maybe in
turn makes college more affordable so
basically bottom line of all this is
it's all interdependent
make sure that you're doing good in
school because i promise you it's going
to work out for you in the end
yeah delisha what are your thoughts on
grades
going a little different direction but i
will say that i agree that grades are
important um however what i want you all
to understand and to hear me clearly
your sat scores any test scores do not
define you your gpa does not define you
because we all know that everyone's
different there's many situations that
may cause you to have a low gpa there
are situations that may cause you not to
get the best score in the sat or act you
may not be a great test taker i wasn't
the best test maker but what i did do
was try my best and that's what i'm
going to encourage you all to do is
always ask yourself this question
am i trying my best
number one
number two
am i
making sure that this makes me happy
and then number three
am i betting on myself
so those are the three things that i
want you to ask yourself each time
because at the end of the day
especially in the world of cyber
security
we're not looking at your grades we're
not
looking at your essay or sat scores what
we're looking at is
how passionate are you
how passionate are you about wanting to
rather save the world in the cyber
security space or save the world as a
software engineer or save the world by
creating beautiful art for the world to
see
the other thing that we're looking at as
well is
are you dedicated are you committed to
being the best person and the best
version of yourself that you can be
every single day because again
it's really important to not let
any titles
anybody or anything to find you
because that's not what's important in
life what's important in life is
is it making you happy
is it something you're passionate about
is there a pathway that may not be
necessarily traditional or linear
that will get you to where you need to
go um so that's kind of how i approach
and think about grading because i don't
want students to get bogged down and
worry that
oh if i have
a 2.5 that i'm not good enough or if i
have a 3.0 i'm not good enough and i
need to have a 4.0 you don't have to be
perfect we're not looking for perfect
we're looking for unique we're looking
for you
yeah i appreciate that i love i love
that framework that you introduced what
about you madison how what are the roles
of grades have played with your and or
test scores and and how do you what
advice do you have for folks
to put that in perspective
yeah so i'm gonna just rift off uh
delisha for a second
i agree with you know both earnest and
deletion grades are important um they
are they are a direct reflection
most times of your your drive and work
ethic
but as delesha mentioned
there's unconventional ways
to
get into that university or that school
of your dreams
while
you maybe maybe you don't have the
grades or maybe you don't have some of
the requirements
back at howard actually worked in
admissions as my work study and i found
out about a lot of processes that many
people don't know about such as
something called an appeals process i
encourage everyone to call their
admissions department and you know let's
say you do receive a no from a
university first and foremost a no is
only two letters so
i know it may it may stink in the time
being but again it's only two letters
there's
possibilities and
ways to get that acceptance if you would
call their admissions department and
just hey if you guys have an appeals
process and in that appeals process you
essentially go before a group of people
and
i'm gonna say plead your case because
that sounds weird but
you explained to them you know hey i had
i was testing low in this subject
because of this you know my act score
is um
low because of this situation or really
just explaining to them hey i would love
to be at this university i would be an
asset to this university i i want to be
here
and a lot of times those universities
will hear you at and hopefully
a lot of the times those denials turns
into acceptances i just wanted to add
that in there yeah that's super helpful
you know my takeaway hearing you all and
just gels with what i think too is as
all of y'all said grades are valuable
they're a valuable indicator they can
correlate with your work ethic and your
critical thinking skills and all of that
and if you get good grades and if you
get good test scores it will open up
doors for you people will give you the
benefit of the doubt but with that said
if you don't get them
one i've seen the trend matters more
than the absolute so if you have some
weaker grades but they improve over time
that's a great thing in fact that some
ways shows
something even more special about your
character that you can overcome some of
that adversity uh and that even if your
grades aren't where you want or your
standardized test scores as you just
mentioned madison and alicia mentioned
this a lot as well that there's other
ways to show what you're capable of and
frankly the further you get from college
the further that people are going to
index on other things
other than those grades and i would say
the other way around we also all know
students who have straight a's but if
they didn't or perfect standardized test
scores but if they didn't do the things
that all of y'all have done when you in
your
ask a lot of questions
always be pushing yourself as delesha
mentioned am i am i taking a bet on
myself am i stepping out of my comfort
zone am i willing to take some risks am
i willing to to go talk to people and
risk getting rejected a lot of folks
i've seen a lot of very capable people
afraid to apply for an opportunity for
fear of rejection and you know the only
way to guarantee that you're going to
get rejected is when you don't apply
for for something and and you see that
you see that over and over again
one one other question
and there's a ton that are coming up on
on social media right now
if you're a young person and you have
this trade-off between
there's something your parents or
society is telling you you should do
because it's perceived as a pragmatic
profession that you can make a good
income versus something that you're like
but my heart is there how do you
navigate that because at the end of the
day you do have to pay the bills and you
do have to find a job but at the same
time you don't want to be miserable
doing it and similarly
if people are like well there's my dream
school but it's you know even after
financial aid is going to cost me tens
of thousands of dollars a year versus
there's another school that's pretty
good but it's you know it's it's going
to be less
how do you recommend people navigate
these types of tensions these types of
trade-offs i'll start with you ernest
yeah for sure um and it's kind of funny
because like my path has been pretty
linear like
i love computer science in high school
getting in college i'm a software
engineer now right
my trade-off or what i realize i'm very
passionate about is actually doing work
just like this talking to high school
middle school students college students
and making sure that they have all the
keys necessary to get to the school that
they want to but then also get to feel
that they want to bias towards the tech
industry of course right i think the
cool part about the tech industry is
that there is a lot of leniency i would
say for you to work on passion projects
hobbies that you also want to do but i
would not be able to have um create code
house and just so like we haven't talked
too much about code house but it's our
nonprofit that has now raised three
million dollars in just the last two
years um i would not have been able to
dedicate time like that if i
wasn't working at a place like google
where i had a lot of love and support
from not only my co-workers my manager
but the organization overall to
make sure i'm opening that door and
providing these opportunities for other
students right and so the cool thing
about the tech ministry not only the
jobs a little bit lenient but the tech
industry covers every field imaginable
right now i literally have friends that
you know of course work at the major
tech ferns but other people that work in
sports right at the hawks or the falcons
and you know down here in atlanta to the
golden state warriors so if you're into
sports but you want to make a lot of
money right out of college you can go
into tech and maybe be one of their
engineers on the team so there is a way
for you to try to balance it out and
like my parents installed on me at a
very very
a young age that i can do a lot and i
can do anything i put my mind to so if
i'm passionate about something and i
want to merge it with something that
could hopefully make me money or make it
college more affordable that there's a
way to try to make it all work out but
that is why you need to lean on a
community reach out to people who are
in your spaces or in the space that you
desire to be in for advice and
mentorship so that you can learn from
their failures their successes so you
could try to make a path for yourself
one of the first things i always have
college students do
is make a five-year plan
this is a plan that doesn't have to be
set in stone you know it's not like this
is it that's what you're gonna do for us
your life but it's good to have there's
a theme with everything i say making a
foundation for yourself so you have a
general guidance of what you want to do
and i made my five year plans after
talking to a ton of engineers at google
microsoft twitter all these other
companies peach people who got their phd
in computer science and now even people
in the nonprofit space because i'm
trying to still figure out what exactly
i wanted to do and if it wasn't for my
community around me supporting me and
helping provide guidance to me i think i
would be
walking aimlessly so don't be shy to ask
people questions and now that you all
are listening to us
hopefully some of you guys have
linkedins i better see some linkedin
requests um
for me and a lot of the two panelists as
well
thanks for that what about you madison
what what what advice would you have
i have tons
tons of advice i would say um for
college students currently
i would say that don't be afraid to be
multifaceted um there's a world and a
way to merge all of the things that you
love into
one
whether it be you know simultaneously
one at a time there's
opportunity and space to do so
and i would also say it's okay to not
know what you're doing um totally
totally okay i think in this age of
social media and almost the
instant gratification culture it's
almost a pressure to know
all the time like hey yeah i know how to
do that or yeah i know what's going on
or yeah like i'm going to do this and do
that but oftentimes
we don't know
so i would say you know as i said
previously asking questions and grabbing
advice whether
you know not saying there's going to be
a a
you know almighty knowing person that is
going to pas paid your have your
pave there you go
pave your way to success but there's
going to be individuals who add bricks
to that road and that's going to help
you essentially get to where you need to
be
yeah and alicia
yeah similar to what madison was saying
you know none of us are one-dimensional
so don't be afraid to lean into other
things that you're passionate about
and use that as your stepping stone so
you want to think of whatever your
current job or career is that you end
into from the beginning um as a stepping
stone
utilize that time that you have to
build on those passion projects start
training
after work start building out different
projects whether it's art project or
whether it's a coding project and you're
learning how to code or if you're trying
to learn cyber security and you want to
check out cyber start america and
possibly earn scholarships for college
just by playing a fun cyber security
game whatever it is
just utilize the resources that you have
to get you to where you want to go
because again you don't have to stay
where you are forever so whether it's a
job at starbucks or a target or once you
graduate from college and you get your
first real job out of college use that
as a stepping stone don't look at it as
oh man i have to stay here forever you
don't just use it again as the stepping
stone as we already kind of stated those
building blocks and as ernest said use
it as a foundation to leapfrog into the
career that you want to be in um and to
create a path for yourself where you see
success and happiness
yeah and maybe one last question this
has been super hot i could talk to y'all
for hours uh we get we're getting a
couple of questions about people who i
think are a little bit unsure about
college itself going back to our
original title is college right for me a
banana boat says i feel like college
really isn't for me what career paths
can i go into and pursue without having
to do college uh we have
raslana saying my big problem is not
knowing enough about college how to
navigate all of this stuff you know what
would you say to these students who seem
to be a little bit on the fence one do
they have to go to college are there uh
reasonable paths if college isn't right
for them but but also how would you have
them think about that and maybe college
is right for them i oh take it in any
order let's start with you madison
yeah so i can say first and foremost no
college isn't for everyone and that's
okay it's it really is okay there's
especially now
with you know us working from home and
things being so readily available within
our you know within our home spaces
there's training programs you know
there's a lot offered through
google as well as linkedin and you know
ways you can learn tangible skills and
get the
i guess the almost the validation that
college does provide in different means
so i i do linkedin learning all the time
and i learn new things get certificates
and they're able to build up my resume
in that way so
just because you know college
is something that's so i guess ingrained
within
our society psyche you don't necessarily
have to do college if you don't believe
it's for you because at the end of the
day if you go into something that isn't
for you you're going to end up just not
wanting to do it and that is you know
time money spent and things that sort
where you could have been kind of
focusing in things where you do like
um
but i will say college does provide a
lot of perspective not only in education
but i learned a lot about people
and
personalities and ways to work with
people and gain skills in that area
which then helped me in my post career i
learned a lot about you know going to
school out of state i learned about
different cultures and things that also
aided in my education and aided me
writing papers getting me learning new
history to figure some things out
so i would say no college isn't for
everyone but i do see benefits in going
yeah thanks what about you alicia what
would you say to these folks who might
be a little bit on the fence
yeah
college is in the end all but y'all and
you can also look at it from a sense of
there are other unique ways where you'll
still get the knowledge people may call
it call it college some people may call
it trade school but there's different
pathways alternatives that you can take
like madison stated there are training
programs where you'll still learn the
skills but it's not like a traditional
college you have a community college
route or you check local tech schools
where you're able to learn trade whether
it's to become a hvac or ac technician a
mechanic we always need someone to work
on our cars um construction we always
need something built houses schools
hospitals um all the way to tech i'm
sure ernest is going to talk to this as
well but
taking cyber security is huge and there
are a ton of people
who look like you who look like me who
are from various walks of life who are
16 year olds who are 60 year olds
whether you're new
to
discovering and figuring out what you
want to do or you're someone who wants
to transition you're like
i want to change my career i want to
change my job i want something different
i want something new there's always an
opportunity through certifications
and those are everywhere they're endless
online whether it's through google
whether it's through a sans institute
whether it's through a corsair
udemy
whoever
there are opportunities for you to gain
skills and educate yourself without
going that traditional route of a on
campus or traditional college and there
are also other colleges out there like
my college where you have that
flexibility to be yourself and it's not
in that traditional structure you pretty
much build your schedule you're able to
work on your own time and you have the
opportunity to not only gain hands-on
skills without the fluff but once you
graduate you're actually able to step
into a career that is fulfilling fun and
again you get to save the world so
why wouldn't you want to
to take a chance on that
absolutely and ernest
your advice
yeah so this question is a good one um
i'm gonna take my google hat off because
i know i've been a great recruiter for
google today
oh and this
question comes up a lot um recently
especially since like most tech
companies actually
took off the requirement for
a college level degree in order to apply
for entry level positions so right now
you don't need to go to college to get a
job at google i'm going to put a big
asterisk there though
because if you can go to college or
if you're on the fence please just try
if you're able to if you're able to
afford it go to the place that's most
affordable because
getting some kind of formal education
does open doors for you i'll put it i
went to i'm a computer scientist you
know i'm a software engineer i love to
think of numbers when i got to google
google reviewed two
million around the world resumes four
applications two million right so of
that just think of how many people are
college educated versus non-college
educated different kind of requirements
there's a lot of competition in the
world i don't say that to scary because
if i was able to get google trust me
everyone listening to this call can also
land a job at google right i say that to
say that
whether organizations realize or not
there is some biases towards
people getting some sort of formal
education
so there's so many different ways to get
more vocational education you know
delicious mess about certificates
training programs
community college if you guys don't know
community college is a great opportunity
where you can
for most places go to
a school local in your community and get
an associate's degree for
little to no money at all there's a lot
of scholarships to get to community
college and then a lot of those colleges
have programs to then transition to
state schools in the same state that
you're in so like for madison and i we
had middlesex county college a lot of
our classmates went there and then
transitioned over to rutgers university
that's a great way to still get formal
education at less of a cost rather than
paying for rutgers for 40 years
that on top of doing things like work
study where you actually can get paid
during the school year to do a job
having some role
in at the university or college that you
attend on top of maybe even being a ra
ras normally get free housing uh for
their institution doing research if you
come into the tech industry there's a
lot of schools that do research i was
doing research at morehouse and i was
getting checks every month just to do
research on computer science so there's
different ways to make college
affordable so i always strive to tell
students if you can afford it if you can
make it happen
please go to college because it's gonna
help set you up for the rest of things
uh in your life so that's that's my bias
on it
right now
yeah no well thanks all of y'all for
giving very honest and i think authentic
answers which everyone really wants you
know i'll give my last few few cents on
that last question
um i agree with everything i've all of
y'all said uh there are other there are
other pathways and there's increasingly
you know in in the past the other
pathways people might have said trade
school and whatever and even those those
can be
higher compensating than people
recognize i once spoke at the
national electric
electrician association and
you could get an apprenticeship uh after
doing some intro courses and then once
you're done with the apprenticeship you
could be making six figures so there is
there could be very good careers in the
trades but as many of y'all alluded to
many of the the jobs that we associate
with college degrees like becoming a
software engineer or working in cyber
security there now might be alternative
pathways google and others have
certification mechanisms where uh that
type of thing can happen uh but with
that said and i think ernest you alluded
to i think everyone alluded to this that
it's still where society is right now
college tends to be the most likely
pathway and you know i just reflected
people who had a little bit of time to
reflect on their their 20s and pretty
much anyone who went to college and
finished does not regret it they don't
say i wish i didn't go
i do know folks who might have started
and didn't finish and then there might
be some regrets and so i think maybe the
narrative might be
you know it isn't college robust it is
really dig deep and this this is you
know i'm trying to take some dots with
what oliviel said what you care about
what you love and what's sustainable you
can't do anything even for four years if
you don't at least reasonably enjoy it
um but and then and what's sustainable
financially time if you need to work
while you're in college but then try to
try to put your head down and get that
done it probably will open doors for you
but for whatever reason if it doesn't
work out financially if that doesn't
work out in any other way i always say
there's no right decision it's all about
making the decision right and we just as
we talked about the straight a student
who might not get opportunities because
they might become complacent or not want
to take risks there could be people with
phds who don't don't reach their
potential because they don't take risk
and there could be people who didn't go
to college but they're always working
they're always putting themselves out of
their comfort zone they're talking
asking a lot of questions they're being
entrepreneurial and they can do just
great so
no simple answers to all of this but
this was a fun beginning to the
conversation thank you all for joining
this and i hope we can we can do
something like this again
yes thank you so much
sounds good thanks everyone
you